three-five we are pushing pencils
anymore my name is David Koch I'm Natali
Gonzalez I'm Peter Robinson
I'm Abby Hershey thing about accounting
is you definitely be very used to just
doing kind of a consistent same thing
every day very routine I have a job
fantasy we're like generic like bad guys
come in and take over my office in life
only I can fight them I personally do
not like fights I get scared cuz I don't
want people to get hurt yeah are we
getting punched in the face what is it
planning on that I rarely get to be in
beast mode and I'm really looking
forward to that instinct primal man
stuff hi welcome to our cage I'm Dave
the pain train mazzani I'm the current
UFC lightweight champion of the world
I'm Gina danger Pazhani and I am the
current AFC bantamweight title holder
today we're learn about taking control
of a violent situation you do that with
proper technique where I learn how to
box where I learn how to grapple maybe
choke a guy out take somebody down and
hold down pound them I'm gonna kill this
leg by doing steer wheel motion yeah and
they're gonna be moving around like one
applause you don't hurt stop out do I
know how to tell ya push me against the
fence and bring me back full cross hook
cross go cross it
why are you training your back
yeah there we go
runs a boat there you go jab jab cross
1 2 3 4 straights go beautiful well
there's one thing I know about fighting
is you learn a lot of techniques but the
only way you good fighting it's fighting
all right let's get the talking let's
get the fighting
touch gloves best friends all right
okay well here's what just happen I felt
more emotion wrestling with David now in
the last couple minutes and I have in
the last two years of my life I notice
throughout the day I got a little more
open to it a little more aggressive and
I realized you know I can do more than I
than I think when you're being trained
you start to realize that like you're
doing everything in pieces when you're
actually a man and you're fighting it's
like you can do anything any one
particular thing at any time and so can
your opponent I think everybody has a
little fight in them just because when
you're up against it you have to do
something so there's gonna be a lot of
fighting in the accounting office at
work now we're just gonna experiment
with it accounting Fight Club